I
I'm here with a Grand Master ray Robson
ray even though you're still yet to
reach your 20th birthday you're still
one of the youngest players here and
you've had a lot of experience so we
can't really call you a newcomer but
what's it going to take for you to win
your first US Championship well let it
turn with this strong I mean definitely
i'll have to play near or at my best and
you know maybe get a little bit lucky
but yeah because it's very strong
tournament i'm probably six seed so
don't lean definitely have to have a
really great tournament now you have any
chance of qualifying for the lean bad
team or would you have to have a really
relate credible result for you you know
I really don't know my exact position
but I think I'm definitely in the hunt
there's a few players I think Robert
Hess androgenic opean are two other
players on competing with for the final
spot and yeah i think if i have a good
tournament I definite have a good shot
qualified do you like the term chess
prodigy it was used on you a lot and now
you're getting older are you tired of
hearing that term I think I just really
like chess and I studied a lot and every
day and I was really interested and
that's what really lets me developing
becoming good chess player or not that I
was just naturally gifted now you've
been homeschooled for a while have you
finished high school in your home school
studies or yeah and I'm going to college
at webster university in st. louis
starting this fall so that should be
exciting for those people who don't know
susan polgar has moved her team from
texas tech to webster how did Susan get
in touch with you to invite her to
invite you to Webster I thought it was a
good opportunity st. Louis is really
great chess wise definitely with the
chess club and everyone here so I
thought it'd be a good fit for me and
that's why I decided to come and now
you'll be surrounded by title players
all the time we've got a GM and resident
of the club the number one player in the
country lives here and of course all
your teammates at webbs or do you think
that culture of chess will make you a
better player I think so even though I'm
going to college maybe I won't be
playing chess as much as before but i'll
still be surrounded by lots of really
strong players and i still have a chest
environment around me so i think i'll
continue to develop great well good luck
at webster in college and we wish you
well and try to qualify for the elite
get seen thank you